this is what's happening in our world
today we are trying to get God to change
in our image we can't figure out why our
lives have no power by the word has no
power in our lives because we don't want
to believe the stuff it makes us
uncomfortable we can get more because we
already have way more than we deserve
Jesus wanted people to know so much I am
so real and I am so all-consuming that I
am so unbelievable that if you who give
away everything you have and take off of
me you will never thirst and you will
never be hungry and you will never need
another thing in your life but you can't
have half of this you need to have all
of you come as you are knowing that God
loves you too much to leave you like
that you won't wear a hat wear a hat if
you want to look like you just rolled
out of the club so be it we're just glad
to have you
there's no Cathedral there's no pews
there's no bells and smells there's no
weird guy giving you communion because
you're not worthy of taking it stuff
like that what I love about it is you
can't say this is a white shirt it's a
black church this is a rich church or a
poor church you have to look at it and
go this is a pretty eclectic mix of
people and I think that's cool because
it's reflective of what the gospel is
about like I just felt so outcast they
are just
as I came to Hillsong and I've coped the
presence of God and I felt his love I'm
just like this is home I started coming
to Hillsong because of the music but
then it was actually the sermons that I
fell in love with and it just I had to
come back when I started coming here
like
like why is there so much
me and only why am I not happy you just
water whoa presence of gods right here
and it's it's all about Jesus that's the
bottom line and it's cool yeah
really cool
you
we chose this complicated city this is
what we signed up for and doesn't mean
there's not heartache and it doesn't
mean there's not confusion and it
doesn't mean there's not pain in it it
just means that some of the acid
somebody has to do it some people think
a church would never work being New York
City so fast-paced people don't care
people don't stop we have so many
different ethnicities races so I feel
like we kind of have ambassadors in
every different community we believe the
Bible is the authoritative word on what
is right and wrong in this world and I
think the job of the church is to stand
for what we believe is right to not
compromise in it but have conversations
throughout it
he said among you there must not even be
a hint of sexual immorality or any kind
of impurity or any kind of greed because
these are improper for God's holy people
how do we navigate disrespectfully how
do we talk about what we believe in the
middle of what you believe and not have
you feel ostracized but the nature of
the gospel is that it is defining it is
ostracizing jesus said I didn't come to
make peace like this I came to bring a
word that will force you to the side big
difference I was dealing and struggling
with a lot of my life sexual identity
and putting a lot of my my personal
identity not necessarily in who Jesus
was but a lot of sin a lot of darkness
we can't achieve perfection but we can
try we also have to realize that we're
broken and then we're not perfect people
get to me at 19 and I just remember
seeing the way dudes were living and I'm
like mean these guys were miserable this
stuff is pretty hollow but I feel like
I've walked so far from God I don't know
what to do I got lucky because of a
couple months after that photo I was in
a church like ours put my hand up like
we still ask people to do today saying
I'm a sinner over here I need some help
I want to walk away from this life and
really thinking that I was going to fail
again
go pro oh yes
give you a good family within church is
so important because for those room at
the table there's grace for mistakes
there's love in good times and bad time
so you never want to get caught too
having a church that's good but your
family is kind of dying we take care of
our marriage and our family church will
take care of itself because that's the
best thing to ever do to lead people is
to embody what we believe that doesn't
mean a perfect marriage or perfect kids
just means have real kids have real
marriage stuff definitely harder though
because we do you know put our selves up
in a place where we're saying follow
what we do which means you better than
what you do it yeah so we don't have a
lot of room to turn that practice what
we preach the Bible says people who do
what I do will be judged more harshly I
don't have the right to have a bad day
spiritually I don't have the right to be
seasonal with my faith I don't want to
lead our people anywhere I'm not going
the worse the city gets the better it is
for us the darker a room the brighter
the flashlight